et
[Applaudissements]
comparez tu fais le sou et tu veux t'en
fous rires tu perdu dans les amis chacun
samedi six personnes deux relais
pourquoi tu restes à si tu te voiler la
face
en fait tu fuis nous dira rien
où peut avancer sans rire c'est
maintenant faut faire ta vie tout ira
bien compris avance sans lui vous
regardera
sourit foulée ses poulets
laisser couler
[Musique]
vous laissez couler
vous voulez ses poulets
ne retient pas les leçons
c'est s'en aille je ne suis pas ton
genre qui devrait même pas me calculait
le temps finira club
taverne accompagné d'arrêt donné
maintenant écoulé tout il a bien oublié
avancer sans venir six mois maintenant
faut faire d'un avis tout ira bien
oubli avance sans vivres regarde au loin
type souris vous laisse s'écouler
vous laisse s'écouler
pour le seul coup les
je vous laisse s'écouler
vous allez rire
c'est dur qu'est ce qu'on école qui dit
car c'est mieux c'est mieux
n'aura pas besoin de lait souci
essentiel pour sa toile juste un peu
vous les secours
[Musique]
pourrait s'écouler
vaut le coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous laissez couler oui
voler c'est tout
[Musique]
pour l'heure c'est cool
allez là
allez
faux
[Musique]
merci beaucoup et le marché